for more on all of this we turn to
gabriel DeBenedetti national political
reporter for Politico Gabe good morning
good morning so let's start first with
the year ahead
how emboldened does this White House
feel we know Republicans in Congress
have their concerns about the elections
yes absolutely there's a little bit of a
mix here the White House certainly feels
pretty emboldened particularly after
passing the tax reform bill they were
really concerned that they were going to
enter this new year without having
passed any of their signature
legislation that hasn't happened so they
still have the majority in all the house
and all the in the Senate they still
have the white house they want to try
and get things done but yeah the
midterms are looming and they have to
figure out well what they actually want
to get done now well let's talk about
that tax bill Marco Rubio came out
recently has said that the bill probably
went too far in helping corporations you
you've seen lines of people trying to
get ahead on their on their property
taxes this year is there going to be
political blowback on this next year
let's put it this way I would be pretty
surprised if that line for Marco Rubio
were not in all sorts of Democratic ads
very soon so Democrats are on offense
over this tax bill which is something
that a lot of Republicans didn't expect
at all they expected to not be talking
about it at all at this point it's not a
popular plan at all so Republicans
really do need to get out there and try
to explain it more to the American
people they haven't done that yet and
Democrats are trying to take this over
and say look Republicans are trying to
make life easier for corporations
they're not trying to make life easier
for you and that's a case that
Republicans have to counter part of the
reason the tax bill was passed so
quickly is because there was an
understanding that hey you don't pass
landmark legislation in an election year
and yet the White House is talking about
things like an infrastructure bill how
feasible is that well I think it would
have been a lot more feasible if they
had tried this first and tried to get
Democrats on board a year ago now
there's a lot of Democrats who are
essentially saying you know we're not
going to work with the White House on
anything because we don't trust them at
this point a lot of Democrats think that
when the White House talks about
infrastructure they're really talking
about the border wall and things like
that projects that Democrats are simply
not going to agree with and now that the
election is looming it's true there's
just not that much will for the parties
to work together on things the president
raises eyebrows almost on a daily basis
with his tweets and this time it was
spontaneous interview with the New York
Times at his golf course with no aides
present
she's pretty unusual one of the things
he says that really stuck out was that
he says I've been soft on China you
think that's gonna change well that's
certainly something that he's been
talking about for a long time it was a
staple of his stump speech when he was
running for president last year and if
he does decide to go after China at
least as far as trade goes this would
likely be a look that for his base you
know something that he's been talking to
his base voters about industrial voters
in Pennsylvania and Ohio people who
think that Chinese steel in particular
has been impacting them that said we
don't know what this is actually going
to look like or if there's actually
gonna be any substance behind this but
we'll see things speaking of things we
don't know about in that same interview
the president said speaking of the
Muller investigation there's been no
collusion but I think he's going to be
fair what is your reading of this and
the Moller investigation writ large well
that was a pretty interesting thing for
him to say because that's actually a
different line than what a lot of
Republicans have been saying you have
Republicans across Capitol Hill and some
in the White House already essentially
trying to discredit Muller and saying
don't worry about this investigation
they're trying to poison the well here
so that Republicans all over the country
essentially don't believe whatever comes
out eventually but for Trump to say this
is a little bit of a different line
maybe he feels like he has to say it
because of course you got to say
something like that you got to say that
it's going to be fair but it was a
really interesting change of tack for
him he has nothing if not unpredictable
that's for sure game DeBenedetti thanks
a lot thank you